viele Betroffene
eigentlich genau wie ich und das bin ich
Leid
mittlerweile
aber was passiert wenn ich als liebliche
Person plötzlich keine Hormone habe
[Musik]
was macht das mit mir
und wie reagiert mich Unfalls
das will ich mit der Reportage
ist
am Hinterkopf zeigen
und es ist so dass es bei mir wirklich
noch so aus praktisch wie vielleicht bei
anderen aber das ist ja so dass die Form
von
Schritten die wird meistens nach der
Menopause denn schlimmer und es gibt
Sachen helfen kann natürlich auch
einiges ausprobiert wie Vitamin Pillen
und auch diverse zum Schmieren muss
zweimal am Tag lebenslänglich ist aber
ich weiß wirklich braucht
und ich habe jetzt mittlerweile gar
keine
und ich mag auch noch hoffen dass es
irgendwie besser wird will das wird
ziemlich sicher nicht der Fall sein
angefangen hat es bei mir um die 20er
gemerkt dass ich beim shampoonieren
plötzlich Filme und dass sie teilweise
immer richtig noch erwachsen bis ich
endlich gewusst habe was es ist sind
Jahre vergangen und diverse arztpsyche
der Druck der horusfalls verstecken ist
groß und gleichzeitig hat man immer
Angst dass es einfach ganz merken wenn
ich heute telefonieren
und habe mich einfach lieber da sie
identifiziert und es hat so macht und
die mit der schönen locken die wir dich
garantiert nehmen Sie und das akzeptiere
dass ich nicht ganz einfach ganz viel
von der Betroffenen Liedern im Stillen
für die Reportage
Posts und wieder sitze ich weinend auf
dem Fußboden im Bad wieder bekomme ich
einen Nervenzusammenbruch und frage mich
wie lange man sowas körperlich noch
verkauft
sie ich kenne die Haare von links nach
rechts obwohl man da nichts mehr
verstecken kann ich schleppe mich zur
Arbeit in der Hoffnung dass es nur keine
anspricht dann schleppe ich mich heim um
mich wieder zu verstecken das nennt man
dann leben und es geht auch ganz viel
Kommentar auf der Post eine ist auch
gestochen ich würde dich am liebsten in
den Arm nehmen und mit dir heulen es
geht mir genauso und ich frage mich ob
ich jemals damit klarkomme
also das lassen ist traurig natürlich
und das zeigt vor allem wie groß dass
der psychische Druck zum Teil für die
betroffene Frauen ist
jahrelang hat mich der horusfall sehr
beschäftigt und belastet durch Social
Media bin ich mit dem Akzeptieren
andere Frauen
ab und zeigen
an ihrem Alter Arbeitsort
es geht viel verschiedene Formen von
horusfall die androgenetische allopädie
ist aber die häufig bei meiner und bei
frauenologische Klinik vom Unispital
Zürich betrifft mit helfe Frauen das
sind ganz schön viel und trotzdem redet
die meiste nicht drüber
im Normalfall macht sich die Haare
[Applaus]
[Musik]
selber rasiert ein komplette Glatze mit
Nassrasur hätte
mühsam 6 mm ist im Moment
nach der Hälfte machen
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
s bemerkbar gemacht
sehr
lecker
und das kann ich Ihre sehr gut noch
fühlen
und irgendwie mit Lidschatten
gefällt mir ihnen
nicht weit hören ist es ist doch nicht
so schlimm will aber was nicht hätte
kann ich Ihnen versetzen es ist doch
nicht so schlimm
ja ich bin jetzt schon gesehen Nadine
zeigt mir das vötterli wie ihre kurz vor
dem ersten rasieren ausgesehen hat also
ich verabschiede mich von der Nadine von
der Moment eines Frisur
[Musik]
enshow
schon so lange
aber sie zwei Tage nervös
[Musik]
mir Gedanken wie meine Kopfhörern
bleibt und ich bin froh dass ich am Tag
vom abrasieren nicht alleine bin
als moralische Unterstützung
für mich ändert sich nicht und wenn du
dich wohler fühlst ist das ja super
also einfach ist es denn aber nicht
Nervosität mache
2 mm an und wenn ich dann ist immer nur
auf einmal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin so krank
[Applaus]
komisch Gefühle
[Musik]
und der Frederik muss mir helfen
[Applaus]
ich weiß noch nicht genau
ich finde es cool zum drüberfahren aber
ich finde es extrem schwierig dass das
alles super weg gut und mein Mercedes
und jetzt Versteck aber ich weiß nicht
befreit fühle mich
nicht schlecht wie findest du
es jetzt wenn es so alles wirklich
[Musik]
aber so heftig ja ja klar
so sprechen
[Musik]
aber wenn ich ein Spiel genug fühle ich
mich jetzt nicht schlecht oder so also
es ist recht neutral im Moment aber auf
die Reaktion ohne Meisterschwanden
[Musik]
mit der Reaktion
schlimmer
Symbol Torte
deswegen komische aber ich danke viel
Leute etwas dahinter ist wenn sie es
würde wissen würde wäre es vielleicht
auch verstanden
aber genau da sie schauen Grund warum
ich das Selbstversuch und die Reportage
mache
als nächstes will ich es meinem Vater
zeigen er weiß vom Haarausfall aber
übers abrasiere kann ich mit ihm noch
nie geredet
[Gelächter]
so klasse reagiert langsam aber sicher
merke ich dass meine eigenen Vorurteil
größer sind als ich gemeint habe
wie reagieren
und versuche mit dem Handy möglichst
unauffällig zu filmen
[Musik]
definitiv
und auch im Make-up corner wo man
normalerweise schnell vom
Verkaufspersonal angesprochen wird und
niemand zu mir ich spüre
schnell wieder weg
und irgendwie fühlt man sich
physisch nackt
einfach ausgestellt halt mich im Umfeld
ohne Harz zeigen fallt man wesentlich
Aktion meistens Schock und überraschige
das merke ich auch wenn ich es zwei gute
Freundinnen zeige
genau
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
extrem schnell drauf viel schneller als
ich selber
[Musik]
das da bin ich verwundert ja ich muss
Körperstellen weil das kann ich sonst wo
ich auch anfangs leer und so noch kann
ich eigentlich das vom Manne wo ihre
Glatze meine können Sie mit voll Porno
abdecken und mir einfach den Gefühlen
egal in welchem Alter
so schneiden
darüber reden und sichtbar machen dass
ich auch für mich sehr befreiend
spazieren und reden über Reaktionen
bekommen
Community aufzubauen wo Frauen mit
erblich bedingtem horusfall ihre
Erfahrungen tschüss
[Musik]
vorerst mache weiter und hoffe dass ich
meine kopfhauten oder gewöhnt der
horusfall ist nämlich ziemlich im
Hintergrund gerutscht im Alltag
seitrasiert haben
aber es ist wirklich extrem befreiend
ich tun kann
zum ersten Mal abrasiert hat und ich
habe einiges erlebt sie den letzten paar
Wochen vor allem habe ich sehr viel über
mich selber gelernt ich habe gemerkt
dass meine eigene vorurteilung
vor allem die Angst was den andere Leute
über mich könnte danke und ich habe
festgestellt dass sie nur Gedanken wenn
ich ja so oder so nicht habe
vielleicht logisch
und der Druck dass ich der Haarausfall
muss verstecken ist mit den abrasierte
Haar einfach weg
ich weiß aber auch das ist natürlich
nicht für jede Frau wo horusfall hat die
Lösung
jetzt nimmt mich wunderbar
vorstellen oder haben die vielleicht
sogar selber schon Erfahrungen gemacht
mit horusfall oder solchen unfällt dann
die Kommentar und wenn der mir vorweg 20
abonnieren